[Music]
all right so we already covered the the
second part to this question was by what
means do they overcome the devil we see
that see that in revelation 12 11 that's
right
which we covered before by the word of
the word of the lamb and by the the
blood of the lamb by the word of their
testimony
now let me comment on the blood of the
lamb
the bible frequently refers to the blood
of christ
we know from leviticus 17 11 the life is
in the blood
the blood carries the life is the blood
is a carrier of the life now when christ
was in gethsemane he shed blood but that
wasn't the payment for sin are you
following me because if you change his
mind and gone back
we will still be lost so he shed blood
and geth family but that was not the
giving of his life and so when we talk
about the blood of christ we mean the
life of christ we have poured out his
soul unto death as isaiah 53 tells us
and so the the blood of christ is the
life of christ lived in us you
understand to accept that victorious
life as mine through surrender to christ
that's how we overcome by the blood of
the lamb and by the word of the
testimony we have demonstrated that we
will be faithful to thus set the lord
regardless of external circumstances the
blood of the lamb
the sacrifice of christ which is the
life of christ given for us and our
faithfulness by his indwelling power
to god's standard of righteousness which
is his law because often the word
testimony refers to the law of god
amen amen
a lot of us don't understand obedience
releases power
people ask me how do i keep the sabbath
by keeping it and that sounds funny but
an attempt to obey releases power a
genuine attempt to obey brings power to
obey you don't wait for power to obey
and when it comes then you obey in
obeying the power is released and a lot
of us do not understand that don't wait
for power start obeying and the power
work as you make a genuine attempt to
obey god because that power is god's
life himself or the life of christ
amen amen so elders i'm going to move on
to the last question that we have here
ellen white writes in last events
page 254 paragraph three
and i quote
it is often the case
that trouble is greater in anticipation
than in reality yes but this is not true
of the crisis before us
so
what are ways
god's people can practically prepare for
the time of trouble
simple
jesus told us
in luke 16 10
he that is faithful in that which is
least
is faithful also in much
if we're faithful to god now
excuse me
regarding the little challenges that
come our way day by day
we will develop the resources we'll
develop the power through christ to
handle the big ones that are coming
he that is faithful in that which is
least
is faithful also in much and he that is
unjust or unfaithful in release is
unfaithful and unjust also in much so
that's a fundamental principle be
faithful to god now in the little things
you will develop the immunity to handle
the large challenge to come the other
principle is matthew 16 24 i believe it
is what is the man profited if against
the whole world and loses in soul
make christ your priority
make the kingdom of god your priority
strip
secular things which are not all bad
strip them of the high position they
have held in your life and give that
honor to spiritual things make that your
priority my listening friend that and
being faithful in the little things
that will prepare you and me to handle
the terrible times
that are coming and they are coming at
first some people say well just before
probation closes i'll repent no no no no
you won't have the capacity to repent
the time to get ready for the time of
trouble is now not when it comes
and so the two principles one be
faithful in little duties little things
the honor god honor god and everything
to
make the kingdom of god
your priority it was for jesus it was
for his predecessor john the baptist it
was for the disciples it was for the
pioneers of this church it must be for
us
amen
so we can say something else
yes
make bible study a priority because the
deceptions that are coming will be so
overpowering without a clear grasp of
truth we will not detect truth from
error let me say that again make the
study of the word of god and the
practice of this word are unchallenged
priority for that alone will allow you
and me to detect the overpowering
deceptions that are coming upon us
amen everything
is good get it but it will not protect
you against error are you following me
high position they're fine daniel had
one joseph had one nehemiah had one they
do not defend against error the only
defense against error is thus said the
lord studied and obeyed not just study
for academic grade studied as a way of
life studies as a source of sustaining
power
amen so there has to be that indwelling
power that comes from
god there must be
you don't get drunk by smelling alcohol
you get drunk by taking it in
you become strong by taking christ in
keeping him ill through constant
obedience to his word
that's right that's right
this is serious business my good sister
this is a lot of christians are just
going to church once a week maybe not
even that and life is usual
life as usual is no preparation for the
time that is coming if you want to look
at the dangers of life as usual read
luke 17 26 to 30 where the days of noah
the days of lord that is eating and
drinking and marrying giving in marriage
building planting whatever that's life
as life as usual is no preparation for
the time that's coming upon us
amen
solemn words that we have to take in
friends all of us
okay all of us
[Music]
you